[Applaudissements]
jean capteurs besoins du club après
celle envers assure isabelle bien
entendu les chiffres on a les tops les
flops et on a on a des images on a des
on a des nouvelles jugées rennes
stargate tombe ça bouge
it is moving nation l'anglais ça va
tomber
besson a plutôt bien magnifique toi
merci - vous d'une élégance
ouais mais c'est ça c'est parce que vous
m'aviez passer ça vous avez une question
bébé mais bien évidemment tout de suite
une question sous la neige bonjour je
m'appelle vincent j'adore l'ambiance
dans votre émission
donc je voulais savoir d'où vraiment
tous amis dans la vie ou juste une bande
de faux cul comme tous les gens de la
télé
je comprends ces questions mais je pense
que vous exagérez vincent ya pas que des
hypocrites à la télé ou sinon ils ont
une bonne raison de l'être comme comme
jean-michel mer par exemple quand il
flatte cyril il a un projet il sait
qu'il allonge la distance qui le sépare
du pôle emploi et en plus il le fait
toujours avec beaucoup de finesse en moi
j'ai l'oeil parce que je ne connais bien
mais vous suis sûr que en regardant ces
images
à aucun moment vous allez vous dire
qu'il exagère un gentil il adore vous
savez ah bah il faut le savoir
alors moi ça veut dire bravo à toi
quelle langue tu dises que ça mais il
aime bien dire que narre série là et
comme il est très joueur il profite du
bruit sur le plateau pour le glisser des
chroniqueurs comme ici vous avez frère
maxime gay ni non c'est charmant c'est
pas parce que tu cominotto rien maxime
est persuadé que si on lui dit des mots
doux
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire je vous aime beaucoup
alors inquiet pas faux cul dans l'équipe
c'est évidemment matthieu delormeau à
lui quand il doit dire quelque chose à
quelqu'un il va direct n'a pas peur là
vous allez voir il parlait de son
ancienne place autour de la table quand
il était assis ici à ses côtés des
invités
[Musique]
merci pour
qui vont bien
donné raison
cdg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
c'est bizarre cette envie dans ce cas là
c'est un peu sans surprise qu'on
travaille très fort match et il se
démonte jamais un et techniquement
franchement je pense que c'est le
meilleur j'ai cherché dans tout le paf
actuelle seul qui est capable
d'applaudir en insultant il ya plein de
fans qui sont là je ne m'explique pas
souvent pourquoi je crée ça c'est les
gens ce phénomène de vexer pour vous oui
j'ai testé fait deux bons mois les
cadeaux c'est pour moi à m alors après
on va pas se mentir même si on s'aime
beaucoup c'est normal qui parfois des
petites tensions dans l'équipe 1 en
fonction des petits cadeaux que l'on
vous fait avec la vienne des scénarios
c'est soraya syrien tombera pas de la
peine micro-sieste salvatore la vague
alors vous allez voir les gens des
phases sur son brouille un peu en
fonction des cadeaux qu'ils reçoivent
par exemple quand juste avant le
générique de fin
cyril vous balance que vous avez donné
un scoop bidon lors d'une précédente
émission ça c'est un petit cadeau de la
vie qui se refuse pas savoir maxime il
va rien laisser paraître mais il va pas
aimé du tout le sais parce que même si
dit rien quand il est pas content il
doit tout rouge quand ils feront que
félix à l'espionné ou en bretagne
c'était votre info ou sa saint brieuc m6
me dit mon ami stéphane larue me dit m6
vient de démentir le tournage ne sera
pas du tout à saint brieuc
un petit à tourner
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas vu
marchionne
[Applaudissements]
ça fait beaucoup
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas ce que tu
dis est ce que ce sera à saint brieuc ou
pas oh c'est en réflexion
une réflexion entre deux tournages en
réalité continue l'élu sur son nom une
réflexion trop de lieux de tournage ou
traité de [ __ ] part ça me fait
beaucoup de peine après tout ce que j'ai
déjà les jeux flyff et pardon non mais
franchement savez comment ça y est comme
je vous aime en plus vous donner son âme
et lieu si ça va connard non c'est pas
pareil c'est le chef lieu non pas du
tout alors ça non d'abord avant
aujourd'hui a le droit il a le droit
ouais et lui dans sa bouche ça veut dire
je t avais beaucoup syrie puisque ça
même si ça vient vite épousé ayda son
prime vendredi
ouais on a répété toute la journée et
aérer péter les chronos illusion est
grande mais j'ai un petit scoop sur sa
dette et on aille à un scoop sur son
propre prime nous en a parlé en
coulisses nicky butt qui ont bossé comme
des malades ça donne envie d'une
aventure ça donne en bien et c'est le
seul mec il a que des scoops sur
lui-même
y'a pas de ce coup de sonde haut de
gamme est grande moins ceux certifiés
non mais j'y crois à fond à ce poste
comme un fou bah oui bah oui j'espère
que ce sera ce sera un problème sur quoi
la magie oui bah magie magie lui faire
la malle lit selon divers s'arrête au
lecteur équipé tous franchement je j'y
crois à fond
l'ayant même même lara fabian ou envoyer
un sms m'a dit j'y crois encore alors
cyril évidemment n'est pas un [ __ ] pas
il est juste joueurs voulaient compris
mais c'est pas la seule de ses qualités
il est aussi précis et déteste les
animateurs qui font mal leur boulot ça
lui hérisse le poil à cyril et et dieu
sait qu'il en a des poils
quand il est contrarié d'un petit
porc-épic alors comme le jour on a reçu
brian joubert il avait un message à
faire passer quitte à dénoncer ses
collègues
attention pavé dans la mare
[Musique]
j'ai toujours rejeté une première qu'il
soit posé qui me turlupine depuis des
années des années on dit brian ou briand
touché valeur brian ou briane parce que
tu as vu que ya plein de mètres en
patinage qui tape les brillants joubert
messieurs cyrille ça m'énerve et à la
barbichette la barbe
martin actuel a dit bryant
oui et non
juste prix mais je n'arrivais pas
l'appeler brian pendant toute l'émission
c'est connu mais jamais je n'ai pas plus
brian green kitchen tout ça ça peut vous
brian dawkins benhaim estime pôle emploi
alors que vous avez il est précise cyril
1 c'est un amoureux des mots que comme
jour me jean-michel quand il se met à
parler c c'est un bonbon pour les
oreilles si vous réussissez à comprendre
gg69 cg mer 69 n'est encore fixé à 60
ans la marque était
c'est pourquoi les gens souffraient
alors qu'elle n'a plus d'argument vous
avez dit je t'emmerde c'est un truc de
sniper officiel j'aurais pu mettre dans
le kop gênante mais non j'avais mieux
vous allez voir que jean-michel ce n'est
pas que du verbe c'est aussi un corps à
la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
des visites commentées
m
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben moi je moi j'amène quelqu'un voilà
j'amène peut-être je vais peut-être vous
gerani pourquoi pourquoi
on va tous en photo c'est comme ça chez
honda tout jeune en plateau j'ai ouvert
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à part ça j'ai appris quelque chose sur
maxime qui va nous intéresser
ah oui c'est des histoires de coeur vous
excuser auprès de pays d'abord oui mais
c'est le langage de la rue de shenzhen
la rue mois aux allers retours et elle
sait que j'adore c'est curtis est pas
comme ça non mais c'est vrai il pousse
pas de quoi elle est très axé notre
mascotte et souriant toujours de bonne
humeur
elle illumine ses rêves j'aurai une
bonne c'est vrai c'est un langage un peu
populaire que je regrette évidemment en
personne s'est jetée fils mais voilà
très populaire m
merci khalip vous le disais oui c'est
pardonné oui j'adore gens viennent vous
êtes très potes tous les deux battants
que c'est réglé
depuis l'histoire mais a jamais eu
d'histoire il n'y a plus d'ambiguïté
rien quoi y aura jamais rien non non moi
j'ai connu pour aveugles pourquoi on n'a
pas le même âge déjà d'accord pas très
bien comment ça dérange pas
[Rires]
allez au lit jean michel qui tente
harper jamais rien écrit j'ai pas dit ça
non plus ce que je sais enfin pourquoi
ça a foiré entre maxime et kelly c'est
quoi ça parce que maxime est une tanche
tout simplement non même quand le temps
des grosses perches et nantes n'attrape
aucune
et pourtant kelly ya mis du sien il a
carrément invité à dormir chez elle
j'ai les images mais si vous allez voir
jean-michel à côté il est comme un fou
arrivé de se placer discrètement ça se
voit à peine
c'est un an vers chez moi j'avais aussi
lancé dany saval
l'histoire des échecs
le chat noir
[Musique]
les cdo
drôle
c'est l'histoire
ce n'est pas le compte
je tournais
m
on vous sait pas plus
c'est énorme face à autant d'élégance
hémisphérique tune refuse c'est
l'élégance à la française aux jeux parce
que j'ai remarqué mais j'ai pas trop
parler de benjamin ce soir oui c'est
vrai je me sentais l'épargné en fait et
ça dommage parce que j'aime beaucoup
mais c'est un mec cool et à qui on peut
parler de tout en toute décontraction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'hier sont les amoureux
[Rires]
l'hôtel est tranquille il achète mandat
du métier on est à l'aise en ce domaine
[Rires]
castaldi veut laisser dans la piscine de
minutes de l'ajax celui là est le mec
t'as tiguan pays pète non mais ça finit
jolie je me fais engueuler me paie tout
on applaudit il a cassé l'ambiance
benjamin merci ça fait la transition
parce que je disais que question valérie
bénaïm était étrange manège pour voir
pourquoi les plus regardées fini par
regarder
[Musique]
anticipez deux ans
d
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors que s'est passé ce soir là ce soir
c'est évident qu'astana guerre non mais
je vous dis thomas vous avez en castaldi
l'eau petter direct alors attendons
qu'on va pas faire c'est ça oui c'est ça
veut pas bon parce que j'essaie de vous
respecter ça maintenant ça va un petit
peu
non non ça se passait vous êtes gentil
je joue mon emploi les coulisses de
l'émission moshiri donc et 6 passes
robin est perdu pour perdu on y va c'est
quoi aller c'est quoi l'histoire on va
tous les pouvoirs s'est séparé que vous
vouliez pas laisser la surprise note que
je voulais pas montrer oui enfin c'est
ce que vous dites à la fin de l'extrait
donc j'imagine que c'était vrai je
m'adresse à qui vous vous adressez
je crois que vous vous adressez à
l'écran ah oui et vous pensez que
personne vous entendez c'est sa mère
vous allez comprendre
si survie c'est que c'est assez profond
si je suis ici c'est pour mon sujet ni
quand j'ai kalisa bête
oui
dans les frontières d'avant tour voilà
comme on le sait c'est pas grave mais
l'intérieur et comme l'a si bien dit je
sais bravo et c'est tout à votre honneur
a vérifié on veut pas verrouiller sauf à
l'efb aujourd'hui il est temps de passer
à la dernière étape des quatiers alors
normalement je finissais par tout ce que
n'aurait pas voulu voir contre cette
semaine mais on m'a dit que vous ne
pouviez plus de 7 à biya non j'adore
mais c'est l'habillage selon ben je vous
en ai fait un nouveau dans le coup et
puis j'adore
voilà mon cher voilà c'est le problème
c'est qu'il sait qu'à l'intérieur il est
toujours des trucs que je pouvais pas
mettre ailleurs est parfois un peu cru
comme de la viande ont été chercher dans
une expression de boucherie ça s'appelle
y en a un peu plus vous mais quand même
ces nouveaux commencent par gérard
jugnot qui découvrait l'ambiance sur le
plateau de thé pmp et sur les
commentaires de l'artiste préféré de
jean michel c'est qui ton nom tu
préférais ces drivers non aux savants la
programmation musicale pendant la pub
j'adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là pour moi l'un des derniers des
derniers génie de deux visuels
le métro dit à mes gars là aussi la voie
est maintenant label made in or qu'est
ce que vous avez fait j'adore cette
terre arrête pas depuis le début de
soirée dont le bruit
[Musique]
cette année
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau il ressemble à tout
moment en bien
en propre
[Musique]
évident dans le conflit a pour dirigeant
c'est là parce que c'est vraiment je
suis florissant dans la nuit je sais
bien c'est ce qu'on appelle l' or à
l'épée messieurs là
seulement
[Applaudissements]
mais rappelle sa première télé ou pas
aux tasses à toi les dernières poches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]